okay
been a while
four eight free check
tournament 30 minutes of three check
lands free checks and you win
how easy can it be
how hard can it be all right good luck
let's do it Mickey I should be getting
in round one
anytime now
there we go
okay
I've been staying away from C5
lately
and go for this move
some success
you want to take him right away
take with the Knight
and drift over here with my queen
could already be in some trouble oh that
one
hmm
let's go here
my back rank is a bit vulnerable
I like that the dark the light Square
Bishop's been exchanged
the Knight can't make two moves and give
check
I don't do not mind the queen Exchange
let's get this one in
careful now
oh light squares
I might be able to mate
I'm going all in Mickey
going all in
I think I'm there first
where am I
careful
oh first check
the first I thought this is tree check
what happened there
laughs
sometimes you only need one check to win
the first check was checkmate
good game man whew
not easy
not easy playing
team black okay here we go E4 Best Buy
test pretty sure
for three check it's best by test
okay Bishop B4 is tempting but wrong
I believe
um let me take because because of Knight
B5 I think Knight B5 is very strong
Kayla's Castle I don't care about my
structure
dark squares will be wonderful
oh I think this is winning now
E5 should be crushing
night move we have a chop there
there's only one check
I'm up a piece I could always give a
piece out a piece away to
thwart a check
let's go with this one check Bishop
check I have King here
I'm sorry I'm covering that square
should definitely I think I should just
go in for that it's a free check
and I don't see any
anything wonderful
should be winning
I'll go with this one
time
should not be a problem
I'm not concerned about that either
be mate if they push the pawn
yeah I'll be getting the three checks
with just the one piece okay
back to tournament there's 15 in there
bear barracuda team White
yeah C3 I'm not too familiar with the
c3d5 stuff
okay
really not sure how to play it
okay I'm not sure about that move
let's give this Knight a shove
I am opposite the king
oh I have this this Square I was
forgetting about that idea oh
another first check is checkmate
okay you all smothered me
okay
we wait
I got eight
dj32
I like this is that Bishop could be
dangerous that's like instant
instant mate
put a little pressure on that guy
I don't know if I even want to take him
let's open up this
oh
I should have broke the PIN
okay I think I've survived the opening
phase here
this is a cozy shelter
for my king I could go queenside castles
and I want to invite this Knight into my
house
they have the E5 Square
probably just take
um I think I should be already castling
this way this way actually
open up my Bishop size
oh
I have one check
let me scare that night away I'd like to
get two checks
I have a I have this Rook lift too
I'm gonna go with this one
check checkmate coming up
yep the Queen's able to do it all
right back to tournament
22 to go 18 are now in there
terrorism
I don't think I've played terrorism
nope
why did I allow Bishop takes F3 that was
you GG
Minnesota nice
okay
let's go a night here
um I think I could get this moving
because there's no check on the e-file
in fact I'm maybe in a spot to give
check definitely want to stop this with
Chuck
okay
let's go here
maybe I sacrifice
then Bishop f
Bishop C5
threatening this Pawn do I even want
that though
let's ask that guy a question
you know what with the king castle I'm
not budging
if I get an open H file
you know let's be aggressive
prepared to go Queen side castles
I just want to rip open files now
H file I want to peel it open sack sack
sack mate
even giving up the bishop at this point
threatening me Rook check
having a clear file for the Rooks
killer
it's two that's three
all right
20 to go
okay
Mickey and Tara's entering a game now
with under 20 players it still takes a
little bit to get a pairing not too many
pauses just one here in pause mode
I think I played this player before yeah
I wonder if they were okay we have this
one I wonder if it was in three check
though
I doubt that one was a three check game
yeah no I don't think they were three
check games can you get a mover
we gotta move our Knight here first I
haven't had many games with white
let's try and pry open a file
I think this is necessary
okay there could be a problem
real soon now
I think I might just be winning
it's no
big concern of a check Landing in fact
that one's gonna
be game over
Pawn takes I get that third check
okay easy mistake to make moving that
d-pawn is usually
deadly
unless you have your night out first
like I've been playing on the black side
and go with this one
this is common but I I think it normally
doesn't really
get white anywhere after this Pawn
steps up
I'll just stop any
any possible I don't think it's a good
sacrifice to invest the bishop to
deliver the check I don't think there's
enough pieces swarming around to cause
me a problem
so this is just a simple
remedy
Knight to one of these two I'll often
just watch over this because sometimes
there's this idea
now this Knight really shouldn't move
let's play in the center
black should be First Choice here
there's a strategy in not castling too
early
I've used this idea a couple times now I
think I might want to go again
one of these
really close
I'm not going to take because there's a
queen check I'm just going to leave that
guy there
so I think we're close to finally
doing something good
okay
it's a big problem no checks
no time
check
um
I could check here I have the bishop
check or that one for the Third
okay
16 minutes to go two pages
players
sugar not again how'd our first one go
all right I was white white again
this before the d-pawn
okay
Bishop B4 Bishop D2
I think I could still play this and
maybe I should
yeah let's go for it
may not losing this pun no not quite
because there's that this bishop The
King The King Bishops
are
very very strong
let's go here watch over this and that
Knight can't move because a check let's
ask this guy a question because if I
castle and then go here there's that
idea
okay let's ask this one a question I
want to maybe play here take
um
castling's okay now one check shouldn't
be
anything
we gotta check here okay we're taken
there there's one check it's easy to
lose count
had that happen okay
King is opposite here I have this one
this should be winning
um
I don't even want to allow that second
check
oh I gotta watch out for this
let me trade
down so much time
you could have maybe snuck that in no
that still wouldn't have been enough
checks okay it shouldn't have really
come down to that for that game I should
have been able to find the third check
somewhere
I started a to panic and go into
a
prevent
too many defensive moves there in the
end
what's going on your friend Corey
uh excellent player Ukrainian Bishops
wins uh many tournaments
not gonna be easy
nope nope nope
theoretical knowledge
all right I might already be worse and
now
I don't know
yeah I really can't
oh giving me that check I don't know if
that was by Design
oh that could have been the thing
um let's just go here for a second
one check
um
oh missed that I'm on that
could take with the clean that's
important detail
otherwise there'd be that for mate oh
man
tough cookie
tough tough tough
okay they've been going berserk too
see ya some odd numbers in there threes
and fives
okay DJ
again
I guess we'll go here
just want to get castled
I want D4 and then the bishop I want to
be able to bring the bishop back
um I guess I'll just focus on
development at this point
I want the move back
I want to square for my knight
okay the dark squares
the dark squares I'm gonna jump in right
now
and not care about that
maybe I should have cared this could
maybe be a move
I could go here maybe there's a check on
F6
so in regular chess F6 would be good but
not so sure about here
let's bring the queen out
sacrifices on H6 and I was thinking
about taking an FC or H6 before the
queen move
okay now I have a free check
okay ready for another and then the
queen these two should be enough to give
the remaining checks
let's start with this
yeah there's that variation as well
I don't think there was a good solution
there too active
the uh the light Square Bishop very
often for black is a trump a real
trouble piece three check
slim and Ukrainian Bishops
Doom battle
okay
um
the d-pawn is deadly okay so how do we
get this final check
let's just get active with the queen
okay
one more check is all I need
one of these three
open up a diagonal
this guy has to be poison can't allow
that Okay so
I think I should have something
wonderful
this
no not quite
oh this move
this is the one
threatening check mate
okay and on that move I have this this
is what I was banking in
no checks and that'll do it
okay we still have eight minutes to go I
think Mickey won that game
beat the the Bishops
okay see you in a game he's in the game
22 in here
sugar not I think just jumped up there
gonna get him
yes round three
three white games
hmm
all right let's block
Queen there I think I've seen some line
like that
okay
this queen is trapped I think
killer bees
covering a lot of ground
not easy it's
playing as black
nope nope nope
okay
be a little careful
I don't think we want to allow that Rook
and let's stop any jumpy Night Moves
that one I'm not too concerned about
and still play here looking for this
push
and I crack open the position
okay I'm opposite the king this should
maybe Bank me one check
this could be another
open up the e-file
maybe open up this
one check this could be two a rook will
be three
forget it
okay back to tournament
44 six minutes to go
all right
one of these players
might be getting
bear barracuda
Higgs field
they're not all players actually could
just be spectators
E6
I normally only like to take when
I'm provoked but
or sometimes once I'm finally ready to
play F5 then I'll go for this like right
now
like it happened in the Ukraine Bishops
game
okay
okay let's um let's go here
I don't see any no
yeah let's go here
I'm gonna push
that could have been a thing
so I don't want that check
let me maneuver this night
sneaky night
think this is close to winning
these pieces swarming around the king
and down on time one thing I've noticed
if you if you establish a really good
Queen position in regular chest normally
uh your opponent will try to offset your
queen
with their Queen
but if your queen is posted near their
King very often if they're challenging
your queen you could maybe have a queen
exchange with check
anyhow active Queens are very good near
the enemy King as you might expect
queens and nights super dangerous
I really should have gone with this a
little sooner
you know let's go with this now Bishop
B4 castles
castles to safety
um
but also look to push right through
right now
I would not mind seeing the e-file open
right up
another push nearby
I think this one's cooked this bishop
where is that
okay I guess we could take
you know what I'm not going to take that
Bishop I'm a little concerned about my
king side I'm just gonna go for some
security
in a wonderful Queen post
it's a very active
very very active
I'm down a pond but my queen
wow
didn't see that one coming
Stop Brook there
let me get my Rook plane
Bishop G5
one more
or not well isn't that a third check
oh there was a pause there
oh
[Laughter]
some lag or what
I was like that didn't register as a
third check I thought that was GG it was
okay one more game
against the Bishops
okay
not going to be easy playing as black
especially
and stop that night jump
I've already misplayed it
okay
calculating some night jump or Bishop
jump
uh Bishop there
I had Queen takes Pawn check what am I
doing
I missed that
oh they missed it too
um
that's very close to losing
one
two cannot allow another check
um
I got checks on my own I need two more
checks
should be able to get it
Safeguard my king
this guy is the only one I have to worry
about I have the check
had this check
tough tough opponent there
all right that's gonna do it
there's our small crew of 22.
uh myself Mickey sugar nut top three
sugar not probably killing your name
sorry
there's page two
and three all right it has been a long
while
since we did an arena of three check
on stream good games all
right